welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question quarantine edition it's
a show that gives you too much
information about the deadliest ways
that you can deadly die but only in the
pages of comics and in these screens of
the cinematic universe so don't warn
okay he's doing okay Erik I'm doing okay
we're gonna live it up by talking about
things that can kill you real quick
living it up and drinking because we are
celebrating cuz Erik it's your birthday
today while we do this when we shoot
this on the undisclosed date of this
rumor was true
Erik it's your birthday I'm Phillip
Molina it's your birthday we're gonna
gonna pick up the phone so you ready for
your question yes hit me okay
so in a previous episode that you did
you did this insane level of power
rankings that was full of lies about me
remember that on fighting skills I ready
to do it - because I've kicked her ass
twice on camera so I feel like I have to
rate you - I roll the clips it did have
this interesting concept of like who's
the most powerful being in there and I
then started to think we know all these
people who can destroy us but how do we
destroy them so what I want to know is
one of the deadliest marble weapons but
like the matched to whose ass I need to
kick who I find myself in a dark alley
with like if Galactus is walking down
the street and I cuz I just see like a
giant boot what weapon do I need to whip
out educate me on how to kill you are
basically rody and I'm Justin Hammer in
this Iron Man 2 thing we're reenacting
I'm gonna go through every weapon we got
and then what can do it and I'm gonna
dance even when you don't ask me to
you're getting to dance oh man down a
real quick zipper Sam Rockwell's
yeah that guy rocks well Oh No unzip why
would you ever want to unzip the
delicious malty flavor here right ah
what can kill in the NC you well lots of
things can kill you in the MCU Philip
you know as powerful as a lot of these
characters are there's always some
horrible horrible device that can take
them down
the thing is that every weapon has kind
of like relative power levels and it
fluctuates film to film and it really
varies from the comics so as you said
what we're gonna do is we're gonna base
this on whoever it is you're trying to
kill so you asked me who you want killed
and I'll tell you what can kill them the
the weakest thing that can take them
down and caveat we're only gonna talk
about weaponry not characters yes of
course the hulk himself is a weapon
whose the Fleur can deadliest weapon an
MCU but their characters we're not tech
got it alright so let's start with like
people like little [ __ ] basic ass
[ __ ] like me we're talking beyond
maze okay yeah your your typical basic
human Aunt May Howard Stark Flash
Thompson really any earth weapon can
take them down the hand guns fired by
black widow or Bucky Barnes or Nick Fury
Hawkeye Zaros Justin hammers fart bullet
anything can kill these people heart
disease a car accident they accidentally
swallow an infinity stone or Hulk hugs
them too hard it doesn't make much like
being collateral damage in a fight that
superheroes are having down the street
[Music]
yeah a superhero is using your corpse as
a weapon to fight someone else you're
just asked to be killed at least my
death meant something did it though guns
don't kill people human corpses kill
people remember when you killed gaben
drew yeah no no you have that wipes for
my memory now when I look at their
pictures I say this doesn't look like
anything to me so many references
let's now let's raise it up a notch with
the skilled human okay so we're talking
people like Natasha Romanov Black Widow
agents Clint Barton Nick Fury happy
Hogan used to be a boxer surgeons these
are people who can fight okay I think
you smell like skilled like at all
no dr. Nick West from dr. strange that
guy is probably in the first category he
just rips on a Stephanie's dead okay
well for these skilled people they take
a beating in the MCU Nick Fury gets shot
and Natasha Romanoff Clint Barton they
have all kinds of horrible things happen
to their bodies so in order to kill them
probably we're talking repulsor blasts
from Iron Man Iron Man let's say mark
seven armor okay so the biggest leap
like we were talking about killing
people with like sticks and now we're
using a repulsor blasts - man well
here's the thing a repulsive last time I
earn Man is the thing that I can
guarantee you will die in one blast as
opposed to like oh if you get shot oh
you could get shot in a certain area on
your torso you can survive it a blaster
I'm Iron Man's mark seven repulsors is
gonna do you in specifically we're
talking about the 2012 Avengers era suit
this is after he worked out the kinks
because really Ironman one Ironman - it
was vulnerable to electric shocks but
this is after he figured that out if it
got too cold it would stop working now
this is made out of a gold titanium
alloy pretty sturdy and the mark seven
armor he could summon at any time so if
you were to push him off a ledge he
could fall down a skyscraper and that
can fire out and catch him and then
he'll come back and blast you in the
face with his repulsors we're
specifically talking about people who
like they're still technically human
they don't have extra endurance it's
like at the end of the day they're still
like meatbag blood balloons
that's right meet black buy balloons
me back bosoms me back corporate allies
multipass me back Baloo Baloo Baloo
Baloo now as a meat bag blood balloon I
know that I can be killed very easily
just got to poke my balloon and my meat
spills a health uh-huh
but what about a more enhanced man a
blue two of a man of you will
[Music]
ah so you're talking about Steve Rogers
or James Buchanan Barnes well they are
enhanced human enhanced with the Super
Soldier Serum so in order to take them
down lots of things obviously can kill
them but I would say the lowest level
weapon that can for sure kill them is
Iron Man's mark 46 repulsors so this is
the civil war-era suit did you do this
whole is based on Iron Man just going
like on a murder spree well we learned
last week's episode that this guy is a
murderer but only reason he got away
with it is because there's no body
habeas corpus that's not the right term
for it so iron man's it's a it's a to
explain the difference between these
repulsors and the ones you already said
okay they're stronger it's all about the
context Philips so in that final fight
in Captain America Civil War Tony Stark
uses the mark 46 armor to blast off
Bucky's arm he bagged blood balloon and
Tony probably would have been able to
kill cap with that blast had Bucky not
damaged Tony's reactor the only reason
Tony lost that fight this because it was
two-on-one so presumably Tony should
have been able to kill either one of
them if he was fighting them one-on-one
this is the armor that Tony designed
during the Civil War era with his main
priority being containing all these
enhanced humans who are going rogue
right specifically armor that is to take
down here that's right what a guy okay
so Iron Man obviously keeps like
increasing the power of his repulsors if
that's this entirely something to be
very upset what I mean it where is it
where if you just want to kill Iron Man
so we talked about how Iron Man's armor
is made out of a gold titanium alloy so
we got to start going outside of that
type of metal so in order to kill these
armored humans like Iron Man or war
machine or Pepper Potts is rescue for
that matter we're gonna bring in
something that's not currently in the
MCU adamantium Wolverines claws yeah we
can show
I specifically own Wolverines claws I
have a example in a 50 RS does it hurt
every time oh yeah house Nick D of you
Syd nicht look you're coming nicht snikt
snikt snikt that's not meant to be set
out loud it's meant to be read so what
automata P is that you were not supposed
to pronounce okay so here's the deal
about Wolverines claws they're actually
made out of beta adamantium skeleton men
who it's our version of adamantium
oh we're such bait adamantium bros so
adamantium his claws can cut through
nearly any earthly metal that includes
Tony Stark's armor he easily can cut
through his armor if he wants to usually
they're on the same side but as soon as
they joined the MCU anyone wearing an
Iron Man armors gonna have to look out
for Wolverines claws and the other thing
about Wolverine is he has cellular
regeneration so even if you were to
blast them with your repulsor that guy
is gonna keep coming at you so Iron Man
can be like chopped up by Wolverine
right so what if you you make something
out of adamantium though like either
Wolverine or adamantium armor like I
want to like murder that little girl
x-23
I just want to like just and ER okay
well here's the thing about the
adamantium in x-23 and in Logan it's not
actually the most powerful adamantium in
the Marvel world so that brings us to
Captain America's shield now in the MCU
it's made out of vibranium a type of
alloy of it but in the comics it's
specifically a vibranium adamantium
alloy called proto adamantium and it is
stronger than Wolverines beta adamantium
so to answer this question at several of
you asked all the time Wolverines claws
cannot cut through caps shield cap
shield is one of the most powerful
objects on earth and Wolverines claws
cannot slice through it
could they I don't even know if they
could kit because there is something
that could key it that is in the MCU
that we'll talk about in a second mmm I
think I know you're headed so then the
shield is unbeatable by most characters
on earth yeah we got to talk about this
shield for a second because like as
we've seen in the MCU it does not follow
the laws of physics it can be ricocheted
it can be like summoned back to you
sometimes it can bounce off of human
skulls other times it can wedge
into tree bark but it can also deflect
repulsor blasts it can deflect Mjolnir
okay and that's the most confusing one
that it can it doesn't shatter to me
only in fact me own ear bounces off of
it right so it has some kind of strange
properties but that's also in the MCU
and it's also just because they it's
supposed to symbolize caps resilient
character and Americas yeah but the the
important thing to note about it is cap
uses this shield to crack tony's mark 46
armor in civil war so with enough force
he could probably use that shield to
bend maybe even break Logan's claws if
they were ever in a fight broke oh yeah
exactly I start to cry over like a
hangnail it's just so emotional then it
cap is like being a coward and he's just
like holding like maybe he even has a
couple of his shields and makes a little
Florida bet me just like holding them it
I mean is he roughly unkillable by most
cuz I need to kill him if I see him in
an alley and he's got like a shiftiness
to him I gotta kill him I got to stand
my ground
you got a standard ground well if you're
anyone previously on this list you're
not gonna have a chance but there are
plenty of people who are about to get to
who could definitely take them great and
can I need to be able to order these
weapons on ebay by the way I forgot to
mention okay so in order to kill cap
while he's holding this shield really
all you would need are black panthers
vibranium claws so here's where it gets
a little confusing little murky in the
MCU it's just vibranium but the thing is
is that it is better designed it's
vibranium in the hands of the people who
know best how to design it so T'Challa
scratches cap shield in civil war and
that leaves permanent marks so
presumably with enough time to Chawla
probably could continue to kitty cat
scratch down that shield until there is
nothing left with no damage to his own
tech so when we saw it scratch this
shield it's just because what Condon's
have a better alloy of vibranium or
something going so even though it's kind
of vibranium against vibranium it's not
just vibranium that has been smelted
down and forged into a shape its
vibranium that has been weaved in a
fibrous state into a tighter texture
that is impenetrable and not just
impenetrable its shock absorbent and
shock releasing it's kind of like Tony
Stark's armor right like anyone who goes
inside wanted Tony Stark suits isn't
really gonna know all the functions and
how it works but if you're the engineer
who builds it you're gonna be master of
that technology well here's here's the
thing though because then it's kind of
going back to the shield for a second
which is vibranium and in general
danos beat the crap out of that thing
yeah but we've covered before Thanos his
blade is over right we believe it was
guru that that blade was made out of the
same substance that Stormbreaker and
Milne are made out of so in order to
destroy something made out of vibranium
you have to go offworld because what
Kannan weaponry is pitched in the MCU as
the deadliest weaponry on earth that's
what made it such a scary game changer
when kill mugger got control of the
armory got it so I should go live in
Wakanda we all should be living in
Wakanda it seems like an awesome place
the street food alone looks great okay
so we've talked about the deadliest
weapon on earth I've also mentioned
someone like the Hulk the Hulk is
supposed to be the the figure on earth
that you cannot kill obviously you can't
be defeated in the MCU as we've seen but
figures like the Hulk and in the comics
she-hulk
abomination Red Hulk they're supposed to
be unbeatable by any practical means by
just fighting them one on one you can't
beat them certain power rankings have
Hulk almost at the top in the MCU period
in the opposed to be infinite because
the more you hit him the angrier he gets
but the only way so far we've seen to be
able to defeat Hulk is by hitting him
emotionally by trying to calm him down
or by confusing him and this is where my
entry into this list comes in
Mysterio's drone tech as we saw in
spider-man far from home is one of the
most effective weapons that we have seen
yet in the MCU and people fall for that
[ __ ] like it exactly beyond the hollow
deck it changes reality we haven't not
explored this enough in the MCU but if
you had the capability to project via
drones silent drones lifelike images
inches away from someone's face so that
they did not understand what the
difference between reality and illusion
were you would be a god yeah I guess I
guess so right it's like you control
their perception of their
he could make the matrix it's
essentially the reality stone but like a
technological version of it and it's
crazy how effective that is it's crazy
that's all they use it for but imagine
that used on the Hulk that is something
that could totally mess with Hulk's mind
yeah you just project him you project a
black widow in front of them no you
inject for black widows and like on each
palm and then like the little bottom of
his tough feet and stuff like what who
and Black Widow giving him a back rub
yeah exactly just like giggling like a
little newborn yeah so technically I
like to think of Mysterio as like the
devil who tricked the world into
thinking he didn't exist if you can
control everyone's perception of reality
you are truly the master of everyone's
world okay so here's the thing how do
you know that he's not or some version
of this character doing that to us in
the real world right if there's a
technology sufficient enough could we
just be inside of it right now well the
one way that you cut through that
technology is with magic and that's what
brings us to the next tier of this real
magic is the one way you cut through
[ __ ] technology I knew you're gonna
find a way to work in your magic skills
that you've been learning okay so the
next weapon I'm gonna bring up is the
ten rings now the ten rings we have not
seen in ring form in MC but we know it
is coming with the Mandarin and sanction
The Legend of the ten rings the ten
rings are made of real McLuhan
technology and the Clunes an alien race
and essentially they're magic each ring
contains the soul of a dead cosmic
warrior and they can do all kinds of
crazy stuff they're kind of like
Infinity stones on a smaller scale so
the people that wield the ten rings like
the Mandarin how do you defeat magic
like even like leaving marble for zeg in
the DC even like Superman who can be
kind of infinitely powerful magic just
works on him right so now we're talking
about supernatural magical beings people
like dr. strange the Mandarin but also
people whose power derives from magical
or supernatural origins so like vision
gets his power from the mind stone
Captain Marvel and Scarlet Witch both
also had their power derived from
Infinity stones
well we're again in kind of a murky
territory here but you can fight me on
this I'm gonna let's do it
I believe Mjolnir could cut through that
magic soumil near supposedly is more
powerful magic but isn't it also just
like magic like it's it's yes guard
science so the reason mule near has so
much power is not just its route or
ability but it has Asgardian enchantment
Odin's whisper as we've talked about
forth call that back but it has the
odinforce and it has uniqueness to its
carrier only certain people can wield it
people who are worthy so Thor Steve
Rogers and vision because it's got stone
and said it's weird cuz mill near in the
MCU is both like the most powerful but
also one of the weakest weapons it gets
shattered by hella it's not really
exactly it's able to do that going by
just the comic book history alone it's
supposed to be the ultimate weapon of
the Marvel Universe in many contexts
like it we see in the MCU we can destroy
the destroyer armor in the first Thor
movie Loki and the frost giants get like
wrecked by it but in the comics this
thing has like crushed planets it's
raised the dead it can crush the
Celestials armor like millinery supposed
to be a very very powerful object Thor
wielding Mjolnir is supposed to be in
the comics at least like the most
powerful being in existence
theoretically according to some list
theoretically and the reason it's not
higher on the list is only because the
MCU destroyed it
it is just shards of pieces in some
field in Norway that little kids will
pick up and used to kill each other yeah
it's nothing now
maybe he'll also was doing that thing
we're like when you rip a phone book
like they're actually what you're doing
is you're like finding out you know when
you read the phone book yeah yeah you
don't rip phone books
I hate bomb books those days are behind
me yeah but she's like how much she
found some weaknesses and she kind of
like and I made it look like she was
powerful but it was already it's also
implied that because she was Odin's
firstborn and Odin's now dead that maybe
some of Odin's Chara magic rhyme effect
over yeah yeah yeah yeah if Fela was
able to break it it probably would have
been able to kill thanos right which I'm
going to see it be disaster but yeah
it's not it doesn't kill him so then
like we were saying if Thor is wielding
Mjolnir then how do you kill this MF
here again he's in an alley what's he
doing there he wants crack I need a
killer so now we're at the tier of
Infinity stones so probably one Infinity
stone would be enough to kill for and
the reason why I use this logic is that
we saw in Thor Ragnarok that like the
power the Odin horse was inside Thor the
whole time and the next time we see
Thor's at the beginning of infinity war
and just with one Infinity stone the
power stone Thanos is able to wreck for
so presumably Thor with mule near would
probably be taken by one person who has
an infinity stone also using the logic
that vision with the mind stone in his
head was able to lift up Neil near so
presumably if you have the power of one
Infinity stone you're probably okay
against melee and Thor will like if I
had like if I'm wielding the drowning
stone I can kind of water and just like
end him that way long as you have a
stone today my friend
exactly now once we're on the tier of
Infinity stones they start to kind of
check each other and balance each other
out so like Captain Marvel has the power
of the space stone to probably
neutralize star-lord when he's holding
the power stone Scarlet Witch is able to
destroy the mine stone but because her
powers were derived from that stone all
these all these stone freaks have kind
of like cancel each other out ran but
there's still whole level above them
that we that we could kill that I need
to go so Infinity stones are only
supposed to be able to be handled by
people
have like God level immortality like
Eternals so Thanos is an eternal who has
a deviant gene so eternals are a whole
lot they're like gods
so basically how do you kill an eternal
how do you kill a god well there's a
weapon for that called the god Slayer
that's Gamora sword
and this is a powerful sword it didn't
really get a enough of its do in the MCU
but it did kill the a bolused none of
their other weapons were able to do that
this is an interdimensional being maybe
on par with something like Dormammu and
she's able to kill it with her God
Slayer sword and when she faced Thanos
in the collectors vault when they were
trying to stop him from getting the
reality stone that has another dagger
that spits out from the hilt of that
sword and at least in her imagination
that would have been able to kill thanos
if he didn't have the gauntlet plus
three Infinity stones in it so it's it's
a total badass weapon okay
so now we know what comes next the thing
that you can defeat the god Slayer with
and defeat it pretty much all of life in
the universe is the full Infinity
Gauntlet with all six stones in it
theoretically this is the universe's
most powerful weapon even in the comics
Thanos goes unchallenged by the higher
cosmic entities like Galactus when he
has all six Infinity stones in that
gauntlet it makes you the ultimate god
of the Marvel Universe but then you
start to be able to kill him because
he's walking down the aisle right so the
way to kill thanos even with the
complete Infinity Gauntlet is
Stormbreaker so a tree implies
Stormbreaker was the one check on that
kind of power
it's the ultimate God killing weapon so
Stormbreaker if you think about it cut
through a blast of all six Infinity
stones in the Battle of Wakanda just the
world was an idiot didn't go for the
head if he did danos would be dead
Eric I hear you're running out of breath
and your voice is getting higher how do
I kill Thornfield in Stormbreaker the
way you kill for wits tour breaker or
kill anything in case Thor's aim sucks
you trying to kill thanos the full Tony
Stark Infinity Gauntlet that we saw an
endgame this is the mark 85 nanotech
armor with infinity stone housing
capabilities baby
so Stark's gauntlet is superior to
Thanos as gauntlet because of its
versatility
it has nanobots that allow this discrete
transfer ability from one person to the
next person it can shape-shift around a
new body it's basically the fan of Scott
litt if like you could customize it and
what I love about it it is Tony Stark's
ultimate weapon it is the weapon that
you only have to fire once hell yeah ah
oh my god
how do you beat that okay
so though there are plenty of insanely
powerful weapons in the Marvel Comics
but the one that might come in the MCU
very soon is the one weapon we know that
can kill a celestial all black the necro
sword which sounds like a Rob Zombie
song right hell yeah
Peter quill of course defeated ego but
the one guaranteed badass weapon was
that necro sword and it was used by the
Clint our deity no to decapitate the
celestial that became nowhere where
there certainly my question from a
previous episode if that's the route
they go to the MCU what I like about
that answers it means that we just merge
the MCU and the Sony venom universe yep
we have a we have a weapon that can tie
those histories together making it the
scariest weapon that we actually have
crime-scene evidence of in the MCU yeah
amazing there's probably a whole bunch
of other like immeasurable weapons out
there I imagine but this is like just
the creepiest one yeah it's it's kind of
scary even its name kind of sounds scary
it sounds like something that if you say
it five times into a mirror it'll come
out and stab you haha Erik Bosse airbus
airbus airbus aircraft meat bags a meat
bag blood bag meat bag blood okay so
thank you I feel like now I know what I
need to wield in order to take down a
MCU and I feel like most of these things
are probably expensive like you how much
does the the necro sword go for or even
Gosling I don't know I don't I don't
have the patience to wait in those lines
Bing Boulevard and yeah exactly uh all
right well thank you anyway I'll just
run away instead even Vermont may lock
your doors right now we're we're gonna
move on to a bite-sized question a bit
but first we want to talk about how yeah
there is a lot to be nervous about right
now life in general is just a lot and I
feel like we could use some more chill
maybe you're working from home dealing
with like family life stress but yeah
Philip I feel like sometimes we just
need to pause and chill I mean I don't
know I think you're feeling this too
weirdly you and me I think we're working
more than we used to working from home
and just trying to keep up with
everything where we had our meeting the
other our weekly meeting and how at the
end of it we just started to [ __ ] about
stuff yeah and then slowly our weekly
meeting became a drinking session yeah
does that happens when you lose track of
what night time is it kind of paused all
that and allowed us to like unwind
mm-hmm that was nice we should do that
we should like schedule a weekly
drinking session that should be and
we're super grateful to our friends at
Coors Light you're helping out with that
as you know the mountains on Coors Light
cans and bottles turn blue when it's
chilled to perfection so perfect it's
perfect for chillin because it is cold
but it's also very crisp and again only
105 calories I gained six pounds this
weekend but that was from pizza not from
quarters yeah and that's why Coors Light
is one we choose when we need to moment
to chill so when you need a moment to
reset just reach for the beer that's
made to chill guys by the way they just
started this thing you saw this you can
now get Coors Light delivered to your
door directly it's addressed here it's
get Coors Light calm and you they just
have like local delivery options we
looked it up when we were ordering it is
within 30 minutes of a case of Coors
Light like immediately all right Murr
celebrate responsibly Coors Brewing
Company Golden Colorado but hey we were
talking about like stress and different
anxieties that can like overtake your
life a lot of you guys out there know
that losing your hair is a bummer
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 years old we don't
want that we wouldn't hair on our head
to look as luscious as a fat boars beard
right why not does normal Thor's hair
that's me fat there's something
different about that beard I want that
beard on my head sure so if you're going
through it you can use keeps it's easier
it's more affordable to get treatment
for your hair loss and it helps you keep
the hair that you already have which is
what I use yeah it keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy yeah and
what's great is that I was always
weirded out about potentially having to
like go to a doctor or something you can
do this from home where you probably
heart right now
you just meet with a doctor online and
then they ship it right to your house
yeah find out why keep says more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors in nearly 100,000 men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication yep so if you're ready to
take action and prevent or fight your
hair loss go to I have it here it's
keeps calm / big question oh and you get
a first month of treatment for free
which is pretty soft nice ke EPS calm /
big question now Philip let's move on to
one bite size question that you said
you're gonna answer for us I'm biting it
hey this is how big your close finish I
can't even read it anymore you've eaten
it spit it back out okay it's a little a
little soggy it's still good it's still
good at Kepley on discord is asking if
you were a padawan who would you want as
your Jedi Master who do you feel like
you would actually end up with Erik you
know me you don't know I'll make a
living yeah i overthink things and so I
saw the ocean yeah and I was like really
torn a couple of different ways and so
I'm gonna just burped I'm gonna take
this bite-size question and we're diving
in psych because I there's kind of an
obvious answer right who do you want to
be your Jedi Master Yoda its Yoda
everyone knows Yoda the most famous
teacher he's like the he's like up there
on like famous quotes with Gandhi that's
right yeah he's the sensei he's the Guru
you want like can I get Yoda I don't
want this other improv teacher I want
you over improv teacher yeah so really
so here's the thing it makes a lot of
sense because that's who we've been
exposed to but like playing it back and
going through his rate my professor
calm reports here's the pro with Yoda on
prose you got a little chilly on rate my
professor he's hot okay
he's lived over 900 years and he trained
Jedi for 800 of those years so it's like
oh you know that's that's the professor
right the one that knows the most about
teaching he also obviously is successful
enough to have been the Grand Master of
the Jedi Council
that's probably get it you were saying
oh that's a pretty good Pro here's the
con everything bad that's ever happened
in Star Wars is because of him if you
think of whoa okay okay all right
explain those 800 years that he was
training the Jedi coincide with like the
worst 800 years that ever befell the
Jedi when he was in charge the buck
stops with him and that's the time that
it all went to I think you're right I
hate that this is true but I know yeah I
know I know I know I hurt Smee to but if
you think about it if it was bad
he either directly made it happen he
allowed it to happen or he didn't fix a
problem that he received from his
predecessors he just like let it keep
going that way and like blamed Obama or
whatever and again he's Jedi Grand
Master he could have changed any of this
stuff at any time right
but like think about the Jedi Order
specifically in the prequels because
this is the one you really get to know
Yoda as a leader right you we knew him
as like this adorable little a creepy
old man but and he was so he was so cute
and in the original trilogy but in the
prequels that's where we learn what he's
really like to deal with and the Jedi in
that time their entire ruin happens in
that time they're too rigid and he's
their leader they fail to deal with the
fact that they're there people get to
attach their Padawans they have like way
too much fear about the dark side
instead of like just thinking about okay
this is our opponent or something
the way that we're supposed to think of
other countries so much fear drove them
to make these really stupid choices and
then most importantly I mean we watch
the prequels they are so arrogant the
Jedi Council they're so self-righteous
we know exactly what to do and it made
them totally blind to the truth of what
was happening also yeah he's like super
wise I will 100% give him that again
poster on the wall that's Yoda that's my
boy
but is he wise cuz like yes if you think
about it well is he the most wise
because didn't he get played constantly
by Palpatine like really well Papa needs
just a dude and he's not 800 years old
and he just like plays Yoda like crazy
so if anything Palpatine is probably the
most wise also if you think about like
the wisdom he imparts on people I mean
he imparts his wisdom on Anakin and his
his lessons are useless to Anakin also
Luke's best choices are when he
completely ignores what Yoda told him to
do that's true we learned that when we
re watched the Star Wars movies like the
lesser than the prequels is the danger
of following the advice of conventional
wisdom and the lesson of the original
trilogy is bucking tradition and making
your own choice for them exactly and
then like we can't discount how great
Luke was and how many lives look saved
and you're like well then you can't
discount Luke's teacher Luke had this
amazing teacher
except he kind of isn't that good of a
teacher to Luke like ok so supposedly he
trained a ton of Jedi but the only two
students that we really know about him
having one of them became a freakin sis
Lord which is Count Dooku right yeah and
then the other one ended up training a
Sith Lord one degree removed I'm sorry
obi-wan even though obi-wan was trained
by qui-gon obi-wan says he was trained
by Yoda so clearly a huge part of the
training we're years later he's like
yeah Yoda was my teacher not quite God
uh the one other student teaches
freaking Darth Vader that yet too that's
what he results in so maybe not making
the best choices also again yeah if Luke
didn't directly disobey him in Empire
Strikes Back Luke would have turned bad
or died if you'd follow what you what
you would have said so true I'm just
saying if I'm picking a teacher back to
your question uh I'd want to go with
qui-gon I've always had a thing oh my
god qui-gon is really wise I think also
qui-gon like would not have had the
Anakin problem because my big issue
with anakin and obi-wan even though I
love obi-wan is that honestly they're
too similar in age Obi Wan's first
apprentice is this this instance it's
very difficult and so they ended up kind
of feeling like brothers instead of the
you know the rightful amount of respect
you should have for your master but qui
gong could have been a father to Anakin
and also not he's not too dogmatic he
knows how to follow the rules but he
questions the council a number of times
I think he kind of hit the sweet spot
yeah I mean you're totally right because
like qui-gon uh wanted Anakin to get
Jedi training even though the council
didn't want him to but it was really the
way the council mistreated Anakin that
drove him to the dark side so much and
later sequels that's what Palpatine
manipulated it wasn't just introducing
this kid to the ways of the force
right so qui gong could work within the
system teach them how to work within the
system and still change it from the
inside which is honestly one of the
better ways to do it but the question
actually also ended with who do I think
I actually would end up with and I've
like thought back on the teachers that I
get and I never get the teacher that I
wanted their sections always full so
then I was like alright who's a Jedi who
is more in line with what I always end
up with and I thought a do member
Jocasta knew yeah Jocasta knew she's
this old Jedi Master she was on the
council and then she's a librarian
he becomes a librarian she's just like a
crappy like here's the thing too she's
like very like uh pity she's very much
like a DMV employee yes she don't take
no [ __ ] yes you don't take no [ __ ] she's
the librarian but she's also like the
chief librarian of the archives those
people are usually brilliant she's a
[ __ ] she's the one that also was like
when nobody wanted to find out about
Kamino he's like okay I've heard that
there's this place but Kamino and she's
like it's not in the archive so it
doesn't exist and it's like what
there was a Padawan who knew this thing
probably existed she's like no it's
impossible
she was on the Jedi Council and she's my
teacher I she'd be a good choice that's
who I would choose to just because she's
into books you know she knows all the
books too many teachers just focus on
what's in the books instead of
connecting with their students but not
too much great answer Phillip we have
time for one mailbag question actually
before we go to the mailbag really quick
I want to share something with you
sending you a link if you can give that
a watch our fans on discord made this
for you happy birthday
Oh guys this is so nice right birthday
man thanks for giving me a platform to
express my nerdiness whoa we got you we
know your big fan of cheesecake so great
oh oh I gotta blow out the candle
thank you for this scented Jasmine
bouquet ever commandeering my lovely
girlfriend Kelly yeah thank you us on
the in breaking into your home and
making fire that happen thank you to the
people on our discord for sending that
to you guys it's so great to see all
your faces and this is such a great
surprise I didn't know this is coming
I'm feeling all of you we so bad because
we wanted to you know we were excited
about celebrating your birthday coming
up and then now we're all stuck at home
so we didn't we didn't know what you
were able to do or what you have planned
but hopefully we could do something that
was that was super thoughtful guys I'm
very very flattered and moved everyone
in there was coming on to you alright
yeah it worked it definitely worked so
are you doing anything no you just
you're just like at home for your
birthday yeah I'm I'm here with my
girlfriend this is like paradise just to
be with her so I'm not complaining but
yeah we're eating cheesecake
we're probably gonna play some board
games and watch a movie that's what I'm
doing but I want to know because someone
asked this a mailbag question since
we're all staying home what are the
strangest ways we have gone stir crazy
ah I have it here but thank you for
reading it for me I'll let you eat well
Paul I think okay stir crazy like cabin
fever is definitely setting in I say
that as I'm scratching myself for no
reason it's just like I need to feel
something I got
really obsessed with like the 1988 or
something a house-party
movie kid and play dance and I've been
like really trying really seriously like
as if I'm auditioning for something to
learn that dance i redecorated a room in
my house and pretend it was a speakeasy
just so I wouldn't feel so guilty about
drinking in it and I made like a
password to get in you know I was the
only one using it but the craziest thing
that I'm doing it's actually fun but it
does show how insane I've got I'm I
swear to god Eric I'm teaching Kyle how
to talk what no are you talking about
that Stella that Stella the dog hell yes
I am yeah I ordered these buttons on
Amazon I I'm a I've been like laying
them out I'm two buttons in so far he's
able to tell me when he's hungry which
was a big mistake yeah it's just gonna
get so fat or just like being my ear all
the time hungry and also that he wants
to go outside but like my heart is a
heart he warming like it's he's my best
friend and he's like talking to me and
it's and he's like learning and you
could tell he's like this is hard I'm
like I know buddy I'm so but also like I
just need him because I need the
conversation yeah I get that
the next I just MC you character names
that's more important to know that yeah
what would what's your weirdness right
now alright I think I might have you
tops with the more extreme answer this
week oh my god where's Kelly happen
hahahaha plant with a paper plate on it
speaking of potted plants so as you know
I have an herb garden I have discovered
that one of the herbs has come under
invasion by a certain type of pest that
I had been spraying and spraying and
fighting this war on I have conceded the
war by completely destroying my parsley
plant I don't use that much parsley
anyway but I found these little tiny
bugs
all over my kitchen there does
friendliest bugs in the world there they
don't fly everybody's looking for them
you never see them walking around but
you got to look for them and everyone
smiles see one on my sink faucet I'll
see one walking across the counter
they're the easiest to kill little bugs
they look like little zebra back things
these things I have gone crazy trying to
exterminate them and even a week since
throwing away my parsley plant I keep
finding them
pests pests crawling on my skin crawling
on my TV I see them everywhere Phillip
and Kelly says she can't see them she
has yet to find one but I know they're
there and I'm gonna find every last one
of them and I'm going to destroy them
all so I don't know not fully well and
you're attracting bugs they aren't
connected they're different you brought
them up together oh my god they are
connected oh my god Eric Eric today's
your birthday and you chose to admit
this show you were the Freak the plan is
to be the birthday free thank you thank
you all so much for for the kind
birthday wishes and a reminder to all of
you watching that you can ask us even
more big questions by joining our
official discord by becoming a patron of
New York stories at patreon.com slash
new rockstar I'm on the discord right
now telling them that they got your
video and but not to watch the end of
this video because our gonna lose
respect for you thank you for giving
them that heads-up and a reminder you
can also get audio versions of the show
by subscribing to new rock stars big
question wherever you get your podcasts
and they get everyone who submitted
questions this week and for sending in
their kind birthday wishes and reminder
you can send ceará big questions on
twitter using the hashtag big question
or by mailing us at our p o-- box
address here thank you so much for
supporting us during this time it really
is hard to keep this all going but this
is also like one of the things that's
helping us get through this is having
the content to make for you the best
thing you can do is just keep watching
to keep sharing it click those links on
the sleeve for our sponsors it makes a
huge difference it means we get
putting these videos out thank you guys
so much thank you
follow me Eddie a bus full of Phillip at
Phillip Molina and following new rock
stars on all social media reminder to
subscribe here on YouTube to get all
this too much information on the stuff
you really should care about happy
birthday to us all yeah see you next
week bye everybody
[Music]